this morning we understand that the
Prime Minister and the chancellor are
going to go and visit the head of the
office for Budget responsibility this
independent fiscal watchdog
do you welcome that will this help the
markets and calm the markets well it's a
bit late for that now isn't it I mean
look I cannot stress enough how angry
people should be at this government for
what is without question one of the
biggest unforced errors in policy making
in this country's history their entire
approach is to blame not just the
individual decisions that they've made
but their their statement that they can
cut taxes increase spending and that
will be fine when the markets reacted to
that doubling down on that over the
weekend sucking the head of the treasury
by the way that hasn't helped and
ignoring the independent forecasts as
part of the process look people are
saying it's not some sort of magic force
in the financial markets it's individual
people making decisions looking at this
government and saying we have no faith
in these institutions and I'll be frank
I don't think either the prime minister
or the chancellor will ever get that
back well Andrew Griffith was saying
that it was important that the mini
budget came out quickly people needed to
know what the plans were ahead of energy
price Rises which come into effect
tomorrow he says they're working hand in
hand with the bank of England and the
obr now so that everyone has all the
level of detail about their plans no
that's complete nonsense so first of all
the announcement on freezing energy
bills came three weeks before the mini
budget so the implementation of that
well we could have had that at any time
but essentially the decision on that had
been made that is not what is at fault
it is the decisions that the chancellor
and the Prime Minister made and that
they're both in this completely handing
glove together that people have
absolutely no faith and they don't
believe they will grow the economy they
don't believe they are sustainable and
the consequences of this if you've got a
mortgage a job you buy food any goods
and services this country is poorer and
life is harder for everyone as a result
of that so stop these Daft statements
about oh now we're going to work hand in
glove I'm in the Bank of England and the
government are in completely different
places let's be frank about this that's
another reason why there's so little
confidence in the British economy cancel
your conference get back to Parliament
reverse the budget that would be a start
so let's be clear what you think the
problem was do you think it was the
level of tax cuts or do you think it was
the way that it was announced and the
lack of an obr report what exactly do
you think you can't separate the two
things out but essentially
I believe that the entire approach from
this government to economic policy has
absolutely no confidence from the
markets from the people of this country
and that that's the cost it's the way
they do things it's their belief it's
the way they've doubled down on that and
the individual decisions look they all
add up to an aggregate position which is
unsustainable right I don't think people
looked at individual measures in the
budget and said look that's that's
that's tipped us over the edge but their
whole approach to this is at fault and
unless they can accept that and change
course things will not get easy but
Labor's accepted a number of the things
that they announced they they've
accepted they're going to go ahead with
the 1p cut in the base rate of income
tax for example that was announced you
have a similar plan on on keeping energy
bills down as well so Labor's approach
isn't so different no well we have a
completely different approach to an
economic policy we believe you can
borrow money in a crisis that's okay you
can borrow money to invest in assets and
de-risk climate change progress and
therefore bring more private money into
the economy we don't believe you can
borrow money for tax cuts for already
wealthy people as a growth policy or as
a sustainability but you're not casting
yourselves as the party that's fiscally
responsible so where are the details of
how you'll pay for the 1p cutting income
tax well look the the we would be
raising more Revenue first of all
because we would have been raising more
from the windfall tax which is the
bigger and longer tax than the one the
government have put in place we've
already announced things like abolishing
non-dom status which would bring in
additional Revenue so we'll be raising
more Revenue but you know our position
always has been taxes are high in this
country because the government's poor
record on growth so I know they accept
that bit of it but I'm afraid and if we
had an obr assessment of the budget we'd
be able to to break down with some of
these individual decisions I've got to
be absolutely clear with you we reject
this entire government's approach to
Economic Policy as unsustainable
dangerous Reckless and I gamble with
people's futures in this country might
you feel differently when we get an obr
report one is scheduled to come out at
the end of November Andrew Griffith told
me that it's up to the obr whether or
not they produce a report earlier than
that would you like to see see one
earlier of course I would like to see
one but unless the government is willing
to act this is not going to get better
it's only got better in a very short
temporary way because the bank of
England stepped in to spend 65 billion
pounds over 14 days to try and restore
some confidence in the government guilt
Market the government borrowing that
they issue to the market in order to
finance their spending plans this is an
incredibly serious situation and simply
saying look we now we might talk to the
independent forecasters and have a bit
of robustness unless they are willing to
recognize the level the loss of
confidence within them I honestly don't
think this will get better and it's real
world consequences for everyone in this
country so what do you want the
government to do I want to recall
Parliament I want them to cancel the
budget I want to start again with a
proper independent forecast uh realistic
commitment to sound money the bank of
England and the government working on
the same page rather than being in two
different places but of course the
fundamental pitch from Liz trust is that
she would do this she would never have
got elected in 2019 by the way that the
places that voted conservative between
19 would never have voted foreign
pitch that they made so they've got to
do it now it's their only chance to try
and get away with it but it's already
failed on its own terms you know we've
already had the reaction to it look at
government borrowing costs look at the
value of sterling it has already
happened and unless they recognize that
rather than trying to send ministers out
with weak lines of stabilized haven't
they well partly because of the bank of
England's intervention but nobody can
say the situation is a good one and of
course
clinical stability does feed into
economic stability and if people don't
see the government willing to change
course after the absolutely disastrous
reaction that last Friday got well how
they're going to have confidence in
future
labor would have liked the polls that
they looked at this morning one of them
gives labor a 33-point lead
over the Tories
are you confident you'll win the next
election look I know people get excited
about pause but look they go up and down
I honestly honestly this morning my
feeling is not of any kind of happiness
and opinion for us it's of anger because
all of this was completely unnecessary
you know we've had crises in the past
where the government has to react and it
can be difficult there are trade-offs
you've got to make decisions this was an
unforced error from the government and
to see people to see people though you
know they just don't understand the
impact of what they have done on
people's mortgages on their on their
well-being okay because they just don't
care sorry to rush you but I want to get
you back to the poll are you do you not
want to to show that you're pleased
about the poll or are you worried about
looking if you if you have opinion pools
you obviously want to be leading in them
I take a lot of heart from the fact that
labor is is the party people look to on
the economy now for you know to trust
for the for their growth their prospects
their wages of course I I want to see
that but I see it to be Frank Moore as
of a responsibility that we have on us
to give this country the kind of
government that it needs and people
deserves and I take that responsibility
very seriously and of course the
government would say by the next
election people will learn more about
Labor policies and they won't like them
and the government will say that they
will have produced growth in the economy
well they like what they see so far they
like what they see in kistama and Rachel
Reeves and myself and the team in terms
of what we are putting forward for us
it's about improving business investment
long-term industrial strategy reforming
things like business rates making the
brexit deal work better so it's easier
for exporters these are real things that
people can look to and say yes of course
that would improve our well-being and
situation you can't really look at the
government and say tax cuts for the
well-off are the way to make the cut the
country grow and the economy work better
because they're not